hello happy Hannukah
yes it's ongoing it's a second night as
of this recording good all my friends
back my Jewish friends back home happy
Chanukah if you're watching none of my
friends watch Knievel I don't think I
don't know my family supports what I do
by the time this airs it will be oh the
lights are on this sixth night of
Hanukkah I've solved it what's Sunday
today's 2nd it's 2 Wednesday we're
overthinking it
I know that yeah the people are watching
this on the 6th day of Hanukkah it's a
Happy Hanukkah are we doing we're gonna
we're gonna art worry when do you go on
vacation the 21st at 6:15 a.m. is that
when your flight leaves or something so
I probably won't sleep the night before
did you get to save monies yeah cuz I
just bought it a few days ago and
everything else was like $800 I'm going
to Portland I'm stoked or again I'm
assuming I was in Portland Maine do you
know what story behind why it's called
Portland Oregon because two of the dudes
who ended up like not discovering it but
like I was discovering it two of the
dudes who ended up like settling it two
of the lead dudes one was from Portland
Maine one was from Boston so they had to
literally flip a coin it was almost
called Boston Oregon no it was it was
actually like the home city of mr. t but
it was before he had like made it big so
it was like when he had no money and it
was like poor t land have you heard that
joke okay I just played the second round
of DLC for this game yesterday well then
I didn't beat I played it with John Luke
from games bonus stream but we won't
talk about it I don't spoil stuff so it
does spoil things last time you remember
okay so I had the worst time ever and I
killed Marguerite and she gave me a
lantern and the lantern took me to a
horrible area with a child attic in the
older and the child gave me an arm and
the arm was a part of a serum but I
still need and you came back here cuz
Zoey said she'd meet you here and then
got back in Lucas called you right and
Lucas said I have some fun [ __ ] planned
for you but I forget where he told me to
go the heats mentioned a pig so you
figured it out last time I just don't
know if you remember it he said
something about like there's an okay
actually go in the fridge
oh yeah the the cop yeah so but that
still doesn't tell me where to go
because I know where the cop was before
yeah so go there wait what is the note
saying specifically it's on the back of
that head you were saying like it looks
like a copy headed halfway through the
transformation yes because it's this the
pig is waiting for you in the dissection
room [ __ ] yeah that's so good this is a
[ __ ] you've already met him kind of
he was sounds like this is a boss fight
so well look at how the games been
structured so far it was like an hour
and a half of jak whether it was
fighting has no longer than that it was
like two hours of jak whether you're
fighting him or not and then I was like
an hour and a half two hours of
Margarite right leading up to the boss
fight and then sneaking around so I got
one health I got some Kim fluid I have
the burner which I don't know if I need
anymore cuz I'm kind of done with the
bug area did you see all the comments on
the last episode of everyone being like
oh he told her not to bring the burner
well I made up for it I had a lot of
screams on the last one but I'm feeling
it this time okay so sorry let's let's
go back here so I've got a I've got a
handgun bring the handgun out okay
handgun ammo
it's not a lot but I think I show my
sweater for those who are wondering it's
a nice sweater who doesn't love a good
dog I know I don't
in fact I'm wearing a dog shirt it's a
Cerberus Bulldog French Cerberus they
can't hear you it's Cerberus when he was
a puppy that's cute
Cerberus being the the Norse god of
thunder alright enough of our shirt
supplements might be helpful if you're
going back in the basement well we used
them once no not supplements you need
psychostimulants bring like one what's
the supplement supplement you combine
them what do you think about gunpowder
to make more bullies
sure um psychostimulants oh they stack
if they stack it's fine they do stack
yeah so it cuz I can I move away oh [ __ ]
I didn't mean to do that umm the crank
no that was pretty old house okay I also
have another chem fluid but those don't
stack which is super rude what's the
difference between the g17 again and the
m-19 m-19 is better right yeah okay
she's 17 you do have a little I have
like one bullet and I just don't give a
[ __ ] about it I'm just like it's not my
problem anymore um I got this arm bring
the grenade launcher oh [ __ ] I'm getting
into here this has no bullets the
shotgun so I have no shells
I still bring it you'll probably find
them okay
you could bring the burner you have a
lot of room but I want to be able to
acquire items too so we'll have four
slots the burner takes up two I know
so that would push the Gunpowder down
you'd still have four open slots okay
it's you that or the grenade launcher
but I don't think I have any grenades
nope you definitely don't have anything
listen I feel like that was a bit of a
dig and I don't appreciate it all right
if I'm gonna bring the burner should I
bring some fuel because I have a whole
thing of fuel okay all right so now I'm
done right on yellow yes I am on yellow
hold on a toilet in here yes it's right
here yeah someone mentioned that you've
gotten Magnum ammo what you know I put
that in there thank you I've been going
past that toilet for days
nobody said anything someone asked why I
keep making new saves am I supposed to
save over my old saves no it's just some
people probably have a habit of writing
I just I have anxiety because I'm
worried that we've been doing that since
the first knievel as well so you might
as well continue the tradition all right
let's go
so what's it resonable three we had to
actually reload an old one because we
were [ __ ] there was one where I did
such a bad job that I had to do an early
save because if I did because if I
didn't I would have died have I told you
a lot of fans theories about so
January's the 20th anniversary of the
first Resident Evil I forget where I'm
going is it up here no to the left to
the basement sorry 20th is each January
the 20th anniversary of Resident Evil
the series and yeah and I save here no
just have a save and a lot of people
think that's when they're gonna announce
like show off the Resident Evil 2 remake
do I need a key
no I think it's the snake key at the
bottom is it the crow key at the bottom
no I think it's a snake all the way down
you don't need a key to get that there
is a door but I believe the lights are
off this time which is great I was I was
just thinking it felt different and
worse the section rooms where you fought
jack by a fan tastic boss fight that was
not a dig I'm saying I don't like that
boss fight what's that noise
people seemed intrigued by how afraid
you were in the last episode I'm [ __ ]
hate spiders I think I handle some of
this scary [ __ ] really well but spiders
is like not my jam
I just don't handle like crawly things
like that yeah it's a snake door there's
a snake door upstairs in the house and
down here sorry I actually thought sorry
I got confused again so okay so it's not
this way it's the other way sorry I got
confused
I have no bullets yes you do you brought
eleven extra ones what's that noise
didn't you bring eleven extra bullets I
reload yeah you have 12 total
don't miss okay so this is normal I've
been here before
oh it just saved great that's the last
immersion breaker of games is it lets me
know when shit's good [ __ ] I forgot
about that I actually don't remember she
sucks why is she there [ __ ] you grandma
I was just talking about you before [ __ ]
you grandma wait why can't I aim at her
yeah she can't kill her I don't know
she's not a enemy oh you're right I
can't aim at her it has hold over you I
hate you what a weird spot to just camp
out like that's not a place you leave
your grandma can you bring me some new
crumpets please bring me your soul as
well
she's so gross bring me your soul go
back upstairs and fetch me your suit
obviously I have it on me
[ __ ] doesn't know anything about souls
so the pig is supposed to be in that
room right there past
right but he's not alright he's not
hanging up there anymore okay heads up
in the trailer right so he's got no head
so we know well it's not that yeah yeah
he doesn't have a head and also before
that Jack shoveled half the top half his
head off scooped it off right in the
garage stuff moved it's all blinky it's
a spider should heal well get some bucho
in your life where am I going down my
way [ __ ] what is it it was a molded
except there's crawling it more powerful
it's like a liquor from to remember is
it you did nothing
[ __ ] you grandma is he coming I ran away
because I got scared I don't have the
right ammo for this Hey shoot her face
or burn it it's up to you
keep in mind you can craft handgun ammo
if you run out I don't have it with you
in your Lamaze sessions but Keen balls
I'm like ready go I got scared about it
oh did he run away
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] me up
be on fire got him I was not the most
effective weapon doesn't stagger him
no yeah I'm not a fan and I also got
yellow fine but I don't have a shotgun
so I just don't feel like I'm gonna
stagger him right gross
he's all he's all leg it's all sprawled
out like that yeah it smells like [ __ ]
but damn yet legs up there he's shut up
all right so I could make another help
which I feel like I should at this point
how do you feel sure if I find a health
immediately I'm going to be buried check
is the whole from once he came maybe
there's no rap it's got smokey
there's nothing in there congrat all is
the final boss grandma this area sucks
we are well we already did a boss fight
in here I don't want to do it again just
grandma with the Rockets on her
wheelchair upstairs are down you're the
worst
play the game I'm gonna die in here I
don't have any ammo what is that
there's no secrets
I could eat those stimulants I don't
think there's anything else in here like
I don't feel like I missed it [ __ ]
what if that was Mia hey then she should
have been there yeah it was her choice
to be hanging upside down in a body bag
she chose this life okay
so he was in here you check in there
anyway there's a note or something Oh
balls Oh God what's going on ooh look at
there's an actual pig next to him on the
ground yes it's hot okay
let's do this one at a time prove you're
a real man stick your hand down this
pigs throat
his neck páginas bleeding so that is
gross sick he would reaching down his
throat be that bad after everything
you've seen so far in the last five
hours I mean I didn't enjoy it now makes
one of us
oh no what is it
nice
there's two wait
both balls I actually occurred him
thank God for this doorway
got him
oh [ __ ]
I'm like running out of ammo here yeah
you're really low oh [ __ ] you
[ __ ] I'm gonna die get out of the way
you heal heal heal heal oh you don't
know
hey did I did have health I just
couldn't get around him because he's got
a stupid ugly body [ __ ] that was a
stupid place to die we should save right
before the dissection there he is that
son of a [ __ ] it makes me so mad like I
oh he he will push your buttons no I'm
mad at myself because I hate you as well
I was able all right maybe I should just
back up the other way and set him in
this room right yeah there should be a
snake door over there like you know I'm
saying like I'll do those
Thanks one down there's another one you
did it
[ __ ] tell me I don't remember every
single enemy in this game it's your
fault nice butt get in here back here
well it's not a perfect solution but I
honestly don't know what else to do
wait okay I don't follow you in here
what [ __ ] it I'm someone yellow okay
there's two of them still one molded one
yeah brawler where are they a little
wingnut just coming on the top of your
gun what the [ __ ] is it this is some
[ __ ] it totally isn't wingnut are
they just gone snake door right here I
think right but [ __ ] it
there's nothing in here it
we're getting out of here
getting out of [ __ ] please don't be
in here like immediately like give me a
give me some bullets wait well had
somewhere you know where you are you're
back yeah oh I'm in the bottom of the
stairs yes and there's a bobble head
right behind you next to the door you
just came through
yeah see it come here you got him all
right so I just don't have a lot going
on for me right now
well why am I so you got the snake key
you can there's another snake door right
yeah upstairs
all right let's talk about this where's
the exit straight no yes yes
I hear it left right mm-hmm you could
just run if you want if you get around
him yeah cat mouse rounds table how fast
is he okay quick yes [ __ ] I don't have
any heels fine yeah you got it there's
another one up here about where am I
going left left left left left left you
save it up here
son of a you know I like this game a lot
there have been a bunch of times where
I'm like I should [ __ ] with her and
scare her but then the game does it
anyway I was gonna die I hadn't made my
heel jeez
all right so I need some bullets or
something I think I need two and then
I'll save so what kind of she's a
regular chem fluid are you sure you have
three strong chem fluids
yeah I'm killing it and I have this
gunpowder I have seven gunpowder you
might as well make some like what's the
point of having all this stuff makes him
strong handgun bullets I'd say strong to
read strong chemical yeah I love those
near m-19 and then bring the other
regular chem fluid in case you need a
health or something it seems good to me
okay so I think no stimulant you might
not need any more so I'm going to make
enhanced gum gum ammo yeah
bazooka joke okay and I'm going to make
first aid okay and then I'm going to
save I can't get over that photo right
there it looks like the outsider from
Dishonored
oh man those things are gross they're
like the lurkers or whatever what are
they called yeah wait why is that sound
familiar lurker the things that were
like crawling on the windows that's
those are liquors liquors no but lurkers
from something yeah liquors from a resin
so I have to l2 in triangle to switch oh
no is that what's happening yeah you
know Tim cherry from Capcom of course we
were not recently but like last time I
was in Minnesota hanging out his place
we we tried to see we played all the
resin not all the resin evil games we
started with resin evil one saw how far
we could get into the game without dying
and then we were switching the
controller on and off every time we
saved and the hunters remember when the
hunters come back to the mansion after
you come back from what is it like the
deed like the the pool area with the
crank and everything you come back from
that they come and they killed me I
liquors killed me in where the snake
door is straight upstairs oh my god
let's just think about this should be
like healing like two hits with these
grounds
music square is the orchestra
crescendoing the music just scared the
crap I got so scared I like ran away
that's like Fawlty Towers
it's like Spongebob when you put this
foot over there
why oh he's right at the door that's why
you could see him coming through the
wall right there I just saw part of him
can I go the other way yeah through the
safety hole you're not gonna be that
much farther from him but you won't be
yeah but I'll trick him what's that
noise you know but yeah you know what a
lock that we are you unlocked everything
in here anyway
alright safety holes if you keep going
that way this way
no no I gotta mislead left and then
right sorry I got confused
sweet sweet huh
okay like hopefully he won't know and I
can cat and mouse him around here that's
my that's my play around the poker tears
my plan should be
where is he I made it worse I should
just like yeah it's here right now it's
really not a good mistake to make you
know it's here what first see if he can
if he's gonna fly there's two going to
the upstairs hallway see if they fall
they might not follow you
which one that way oh [ __ ] that wasn't
snicker behind he wasn't it I [ __ ] up
so bad I was doing really good I would
definitely kill him though nice he's
dead okay now what this is fine
like I'm not you're fine I don't even
worry about the problem is I'm out of
bullets
oh yeah you're fine now go into the
service so you can go into this room
this idiot he's so stupid there are two
snake guards just one into that door and
then one in the upstairs hallway nice
shot yes took one to kill him but it's
just like I needed like I panic when
they're running at me
yeah I could tell
so here either one yeah I guess both of
them what do you mean yeah I forgot this
was a snake over as well the other ones
in the hallway like around the
so these are both equal they both use
the same key they're not equal well I
meant like there's no better way to go
first oh um
not that I know of cuz I got one bullet
this is like the master this is the
master bedroom you stupid [ __ ]
I hate this woman have you brought me oh
so stop no souls
baby you're so I'm hungry yeah you're
just not allowed to shoot her that looks
like what was that
no that cat looks like a cat oh I see
that yes how you have to open it put
grandma on the bed and fall down
take my hand down grandmas it's not what
I was headless neck
I'm acting okay so - I feel like shotgun
shells are hard to come by
oh okay well I don't know what that is
yet so I'm just gonna leave that alone
it's a clock look at the cute black hat
trick look at there's a u.s. Marine in
that photo to the right stop looking at
me
April 1986 Jack Jack joins the Marines
this is young Jack that's the year that
America beat the Soviet Union in the
Olympics hockey herb nice oh my god I
saw this look how many more - yeah
jelena what's blowing her head off
well you can't point it well I mean I
know like I know what the game I mean in
if this was you in real life you were
even I can't open this right or no but
maybe I should I go unlock something or
gonna think there is one same time as
all other clocks so did you ever unlock
the box out on the balcony upstairs
overlooking the trailer the backyard did
I ever what unlock the box on the
balcony overlooking the backyard near
the recreation room thank you I honestly
can't remember you go check it out if
you want alright just keep exploring
around here remember you have the
lockpick okay
I'm gonna go into this other room okay
dad okay okay
[ __ ] what you do with your life okay
this room seems safe it's just filled
with stuff I have psychostimulants but I
don't know if I need them yeah just
check under stuff it's so mean when they
do that at the same time though you
probably get bored if there was
something in every drawer you'd be like
I'm gonna get something oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
actually what does that mean remember
the last treasure photo you found was a
toilet yes with an ashtray exit behind
that yes I'm trying to think wherever I
don't think we ever found that was that
in the trailer
I found that toilet specs for a grenade
launcher
oh yeah it's showing you you already got
that I already got an alarm set for
rocket League tonight I my alarm just
went off it's time to play rocket League
I have a date with rocket League there's
one trailer I think that's it there's
one in the there's one in the front of
the house maybe that was it I don't know
you sure you got everything here I don't
know I mean I always miss something I'm
really it's really easy for me to do am
i doing my best
there's nothing crawling around
essential I guess I honestly don't
remember if there's something else
laundry supplies all the way up here
they've hit it really well all right
they're walking I think that's it I'm
gonna leave I love this house - what
happens here like the structure is fine
yeah well what
I'm just going into this hidey nook I
hate that woman
okay so the hint was that it's the same
time as all of their clocks a lot you
can do right now what do you mean you
only leave no not necessarily I'm just
saying like you could do that the
world's my oyster look for that toilet
you can unlock the other snake key well
so hey so you're saying don't go down
here no it's know what I'm saying I'm
saying there's just a lot you can do
right now I'm just thinking out loud yes
if you want I feel your soft hinting no
I will heart him if I I don't know if I
understand it I'll tell you this it's
very literal the same time is all other
clocks
is there another clock in here and then
I can just know what time it is yeah
there's a yeah okay I think I do think
you're overcomplicating it no I mean
there's there are clocks throughout the
house that it means all other clocks
right so I'm sure there's a clock nearby
I just don't remember seeing a clock
recently granny what time is it time to
die do you have the time the old bag my
wit my watch like doesn't tell me my
time it just tells you that I have a
heart still which you could have figured
out yourself it's not in here I'll tell
you that okay let's just leave them god
I hope these Shh I killed two of you
there's no more correct oh there you go
10:15 that's the time there's another
clock over there there are everywhere
now that you like know now that I'm
paying attention yeah I feel like that
note wasn't necessary
because I would just probably start
looking at other clocks yeah I agree
should I do that now as much as this
game is great about you not giving you
too much direction I would I go this way
I feel like it would be faster
it's faster okay did you press X on it I
don't know Thanks and here you are
complaining the public too easy why I
didn't know you had to press X on the
phone I don't wanna go down there my
place looks terrible
that's so cool I want this house stop -
that thing motor apparatus oh wait how
do I get out you don't go into the soul
event and dock bringing up the souls cuz
I don't have any bullets to be down here
very good yeah this was a terrible idea
I'm kidding it's joke
you have to admit this is a cool house
yes
I've admitted the house is neat [ __ ]
hell saw blades blood well yeah but it's
more of the is that just a bunch of legs
it's like Salvador Dali got horny when
he was 95 maybe nothing I'm gonna hide
ooh
nice nice what was that enhanced ammo I
think that means yeah for this hello the
keycard got the red one
oh [ __ ] it's saving its leaving Mike
there are two key card you said that's
one
it's a key a bookshelf oh I heard it
look I heard it look closer nothing no I
heard it what the thing is that a cow
parts of cows does he count I heard I
heard him did you hear him yes I heard
him he liked me look gurgle noise he's
right outside this door hear it I hear
him I'm switching to my shotgun [ __ ] I
hate when they give me two options hey
hon do you know where you are no I'm in
the basement yeah
remember this door was locked that's the
the morgue dissection room the morgue
room whatever it was there was a guy
crawling that I left down here what
should I do
go back up so he was in that room so you
could go this way or you could try to
dodge him again
where's to the right it goes it circles
back around so that's the room you did
the code with tomorrow this is the
morgue room so I want to leave yeah you
could go either way but the other way
was the getaway with a guy there might
be a guy in the mold here for [ __ ]
sake the game doesn't give you many easy
choices how do I go home is it left here
is it straight straight straight now go
left that's gonna leave you deeper and
straight in the left straight and then
straighten than a right book I knew it
right right right right right right oh
you keep going here Jim just go left
he's gonna follow you up here save room
I love the savory music in this game
it's it's right up there with dire dire
docks there's a song from Mars I ran
away and Traverse town from Kingdom
Hearts alright so I have a key card and
now I need to go to the left part of the
house yeah do I have enough stuff I'm
okay actually hold on I know here's
something I could tell you so the key
card
I would offload it into the lock before
you lock yeah I don't know if even
remember this this was a while ago so
when you first went to the back yard
next to the trailer there was a door
yeah so you could go put in key things
why
just so I don't have to take two at a
time later on when you get the boom
other color okay this is one of those
times where I'm actually trying to save
you time space I trust you a little bit
sorry every time where there's somebody
out here is there ever a time when like
I've answered my question I was about to
say no I don't remember them being back
here you check the toilet here I did
remember that guy told me to check it
and I found ammo no no I meant I think
it's a toilet in the front of the house
okay so you know the other ones blue it
doesn't matter okay let's go check that
bathroom shave no sure what did you just
saved front of the house backwards Jack
used to wait wait go back go back go
back go back go back
right oh that was the treasure okay
because member the treasure photo showed
a cigarette ash tray full of butts next
to the bowl form I would remember a
photo full of butts Mike okay so the
only other treasure photo we have now
that we need to worry about is the one
with a mannequin head with a head
on it the snake door sorry I'm just like
super paranoid for completely good
reasons I don't know why I assumed I
hadn't done this but I'm just doing it
you've grown since last time you walked
through here
I was used to be a bobble head right
this rooms still safe like could I still
if you remove the shotgun yeah the model
shotgun yeah it's like a nice little
safety nook if I needed it I'm like
resin evil remake and where the ceiling
just starts to crush you if you don't
get out in time a creepy photo
okay all right I'm ready
oh no that's grown my how you've grown
isn't a fish album I don't know that's
just not knowledge I would have a good
friend who likes fish a lot I think it
is
we've all had friends who like fish I
currently still do okay actually while
you're up here go check that box if you
can lock like it okay straight at the
end yeah you did not open it yet so
sweet
what's that noise wind yeah what's that
I hear that it's a crow blinkin what are
you doing waiting guessing I guess no
one's coming Oh Robert
he lost y'all the dude who plays bass
Prince John in that movie Richard Lewis
who's also in Curb Your Enthusiasm I saw
him do stand-up
two weeks ago oh right how was it he's
pretty funny I do Richard Lewis yeah
he's like himself times 10 now getting
older guy yeah
four of them you could reload and have
two in reserve that's it I can only have
seven
okay well I feel fairly stocked you got
shotgun shells oh I was dumb yep there
you go
I thought it was hint a handgun stuff is
this a safe room to the right no it's
the bathroom where Jack's scared the
[ __ ] out of you there's no safe room up
here
this place is death nothing good comes
from this area all balls literally
billiard balls no something's gonna fall
when I come to this door is there
anything else in here that I missed cuz
I got those stimulants I think I kind of
took them in here I'm pretty sure I did
actually I took drugs in here didn't I
oh yeah you just have a return-trip
right now all right
let's just do it this [ __ ] over with
where are you fairly certain you could
viscous snakey after this cool
this room is nice this is a relaxing
area mommy took me to the hospital they
took a photo of my head with a weird
machine then mommy bought me a 259 piece
puzzle from the toys were stupid Oliver
keeps teasing me you're a crazy head
I lied to Oliver I told him to come over
to for my birthday party then shut him
in the Attic from outside my remote by
remote control he kept crying let me out
I changed the remote control so stupid
Zoe can't go into the Attic I melded it
with one of my inventor contest trophies
now she'll never find it Oh Oliver is
dead probably Oliver this is Lucas's
room she'd not have teased him Lucas is
the guy that's an adult now yeah the one
who was talking about the key cards and
put the pig head in the fridge this is
like his childhood room current he still
lives here it just had a stunted growth
I guess weird why would it show me this
honorable Honorable Mention amateur
robotics interesting so maybe the dude
maybe I'll be fighting some kind of like
robot monster engineering okay so he's
an engineer and a robot you have a third
place so he sucks engineering okay so
he's an engineer and he's probably gonna
make some kind of creep sex robot to
fight me
woohoo I see you damn you're getting
stocked up on shotgun shells well it's
never it's always like a double-edged
sword right like any time I don't have
any bullets I'm like I don't any bullets
any time I find bullets I'm like why am
i finding all these bullets cuz they
know you're gonna fight some [ __ ] ah
gosh 22 are there bullets in here that
was weird just me to pick up that soccer
ball that football helmet soccer ball so
he's an active sports guy or he wanted
to be
well I hate those alligators if you
lived it in like the bayou would you
have plushy alligators wouldn't they be
like such an everyday occurrence a
nautical
I missed you just looked at it oh sure
you have another lockup damn you just
looked at it it was the ladder over
there killing it
Oh keep looking around here though okay
maybe Oliver's still out there oh [ __ ]
that's so mean Oh Oliver stopped his
yelling but sometimes I hear him
knocking it really stinks and some weird
juice is dripping from the ceiling
anyway since I had time I changed the
remote control trophy now it'll be shiny
even at night [ __ ] I hate Lucas so much
I wait what is that second part mean the
remote control trophy you already did it
you just pressed it oh okay this is a
trophy it's just shaped like a lamb
mm-hmm all right wrong also an herb
right there yeah I saw it okay I'm good
at this game now that's literally like
we're gonna call it hutch that the word
yeah play what
[ __ ] you Lukas broken that was his
magnum opus
everybody has shelves like those ones
now to the right that white one
oh these these gross IKEA shelf things
something like here it's like he died
can Walmart and I have them like I have
I put I have them in my apartment I wish
I didn't but I do he broke his mirror
all right well I guess that's it time to
end the episode no [ __ ] should I've
saved I feel uncomfortable how do I get
that [ __ ] really I don't want to do that
Hey
yeah in real life you just turn around
on the liar and in real life you
wouldn't be destroying bobblehead
videotape I don't want to feed I don't
want to do this oh god I have regular
ammo I could change to it right yeah
should I just do that sure
I feel like bullets are probably good I
love like the detail like the fake
Christmas trees up here
I feel like bullets are a little too
precious for me to be doing this
installation of a shadow activated
doorway in the main hall is that one I
already did
shadow activator yeah that was good
that's the one for the safety hole right
here I'll tell you this just because
grab yeah [ __ ] I could make no no no get
rid of the axe you don't need the
hatchet that you just pick up what do
you mean just drop it you don't need
that I'm telling you yeah
trash it won't let me press X on again
[ __ ] you discard it maybe you
have to read something on it no oh I
regret picking it up I can switch to
your burner and reload I can eat my
psychostimulants that's a thing I can
also just come back up here so I don't
to guide you too much but I don't think
we would remember if we don't do it now
so remember you got the broken handgun
under the back porch and you fixed it
with to make it this yep
the if you take this model toy shotgun
you can put it on the statue right and
then take a shotgun and fix it yeah you
don't have the repair kit yet but I can
do it later yeah I don't want to lead
you too much again that was just like I
think we would have forgotten if we
didn't do it now do you think you just
come up here later I don't know why it's
not letting you drop the Hat you try
dropping the hatchet now that you're not
like focusing on maybe I need to use it
to like fight the kid or something oh
you're totally right actually okay
nevermind it's okay I'm gonna fight this
kid he's definitely up here how would he
be alive still he's hiding and he's
stupid and he's gonna kill me I haven't
saved recently
ooh that looks like an axe top left
[ __ ] it's hard for me to rotate this
even like the way I want it to be
rotated oh oh hey go back go back go
back go back now oh I see him so it's
keep coming this way I so I know I just
don't know how to rotate it the way
you're doing laughs like I think yeah
[Music]
like we're on the same page judgment
haha [ __ ] wanna let you drop the ax I
don't know yes
I don't what should I do
you don't need the treasure photo you
don't need you reloaded your burner this
item cannot be recovered can I wait let
me just look at it one more time and
I'll discard it okay if I also remember
I hit something here hi find it if you
can so it's a kid's head on top of the
cage it's just a mannequins head not a
kid it's got a hat yeah I remember where
that is no the lockpick I can take them
you know a lot of lock things yeah you
could take that but I know you want the
thing okay we'll come back up here but I
just don't wanna forget that is this kid
gonna kill me can you see like any
remains of Oliver actually now that
maybe they cleaned it up since I'm not
[ __ ] with you I actually just want to
know there's like some poop to Buffalo
chips well he probably did have to poop
up here nobody everybody poops
what a cool [ __ ] house
stop I'm serious remember fear you put
the first beer when you climb up the
ladder in alma's right they're looking
at you oh I forgot about that also no I
didn't play fear I was too afraid my
friends played beer and I watched them I
liked the first
- so what are we doing so I have a blue
key card and I can go home but there's
gonna be a molded outside this [ __ ]
door you can get red the blue key card
the toy hatches put on your save box so
we I need this no I don't know why it's
not let me drop it I don't think you
need it can you press square on it
instead sure it's gotta have some
interest
Liam oh you also have the VHS okay
there's my towel
we'll go to the save box unload a bunch
of [ __ ] come back at the toy shotgun
then go do the VHS [ __ ] you I know
you're out there where is it why don't I
just watch the VHS I'm already on this
side of the house there's that TV like
right over there sure make sense where
is it TV you just said what you don't
put moulded in there for no reason they
stuffed it themselves no I don't
remember seeing that before my mother
beer okay
before you even evitable freaked out
during this VHS Clancy Jarvis back to
him what was the last thing that
happened to him he got the last time I
was him was because the last APD was MIA
the last one with Clancy was the first
one you did okay so he's locked him in a
room yeah oh [ __ ]
all right that's a different guy who
didn't make it maybe just thought I'd
give that a try being resourceful I
don't have any like defense weapons and
and I can't see like I need this yeah
give me you're not using it oh look at
that haircut it's not a real person
get out of here you look stupid all
right
so I have a candle let's check out this
toilet looks pretty normal
wait what it's disgusting it just hasn't
been flushed I guess I get normal toilet
balloons good birthday that's a big
deflated balloon
oh my god that's [ __ ] gas it's
leaking into the room is that what I
think it is okay yeah Clancy okay a
winding key okay so I have a thing all
right put your thumb in it idiot
what not you okay sorry so I mean
there's my Clancy okay and then this is
stuff that I don't know the answer to
yet there's a ribbon on it right and
okay well it was worth a try
so that's blowing out my candle this is
just a puzzle it's an escape room
I like this see how long that lasts
helped me liking it yeah no I'm just
kidding it's well-designed okay a dog
and a human and a bunch of [ __ ] I don't
understand and a rope that I can't cut
because I don't have a knife or anything
okay well I was just thinking out loud
okay so the first thing I need to know
okay okay so the first thing I need to
do okay you're awful pretty creepy I
hate him what is that his hand
remember the dummy finger from the demo
remember people that everybody was like
freaking out about what the dummy finger
was for yeah he's the dummy should I put
my candle in him oh I just don't know
what that's for then in fact I don't
know what any of this is for them all
right
so the first thing I need to do is
figure out what that I think I need to
open that lock pick you know what I mean
the rope
I'm actually afraid that he's gonna move
you could probably mount that to a d-pad
what the telescope yeah just so you
don't have to keep opening your
inventory is that gonna happen
not necessarily I'm saying it's an
equippable thing so yeah no it's not oh
[ __ ] my bad okay
it's weird super dirty oh [ __ ] okay so I
need to I hate that guy
I need to clean the telescope that's
what I'm learning from this we say
that's accurate mm-hmm all right what do
you clean things with with water it
seems to have been fitted with a
polarizing filter the dirt on it makes
it hard to see through remember anything
that dirt I don't think that's dirt it's
poop yeah
that makes them you had the right ideas
thank you so I need to I'm looking for
weird things too right aren't they like
they're pretty weird yeah it's like a
grim reaper someone hanging okay and
that's got to be somewhere here but I
don't know where I guess I could just
walk around using it up okay it is a
noose a bird and a baby bird on a
tombstone or a fetus noose bird the baby
newt newt
noose bird baby killing it [ __ ] oh what
am I supposed to do with that straw doll
all right let me think about this so I
was Trog doll now what's the one rule
I've told you since the beginning of
Knievel look at things I think it should
it's hard to touch that was the
description oh it's like a fuse okay so
there's this gas pipe over here oh
there's also this I'm gonna say the gas
pipe I'm basing this on with nothing
I'm just gonna give it a whirl it could
also be the finger finger it is
oh okay so I tried the holes that I'm
know is there another hole that I
haven't considered what's a fuse right
zoomy a light it yes I can explode I
mean it may occurred but it's like
literally that's what a fuse does maybe
this I just don't know what to do with
it you know what yeah I'm dumb just
gonna like this just in case someone
have it ready you know on the fly I'll
tell you this I think you're under the
assumption well you are in the
assumption that that is gas coming out
of the pipe if that was gas the oven
would be blowing it up right that makes
sense
you're just air it does look like a gas
pipe I'm just gonna look at this thing
okay I'm from the demo that was like the
number one like urban myth surrounding
it like what the [ __ ] is not a myth but
like what is the dummy finger for is
your finger
you're welcome it looks like it could
hold something I don't want him to hold
something
Jia chatter that's awful
oh he's drawing maybe or something
it's actually really confusing I could
give him this candle okay I could give
him this telescope okay so I'm out of
items but I've formally given him stuff
he has the ability to nail are these
nails yeah
he has the ability to nail things I
guess I need a nail or a hammer some
[ __ ] getting closer
yeah you're making good progress hello
I just um I'm a little what's that
here that is that oh that's like the out
the way out worth paying attention to
hear something just showed up on your
screen back there not there before that
that no oh there's a mold in there no
I'm dead because I have a [ __ ] candle
I hope they're afraid of light all right
I'm ready now
well part of the house this is it will
be difficult to open without the
password right I mean I hear you I just
okay let's give that to the guy no likey
balloon room I could put it in here
spicy so dumb like also I never
understood why you couldn't pop it
yourself with your hand also I do really
like how it's like VHS shitty audio
still yeah yeah that's cool and that
it's kind of like film grainy it's you
can see it like in the lines
everything's got like a film on it what
is call scanlines
I got Japan okay right for me baby I
knew that guy was gonna be gross loser
well obviously you have to go really
deep to write on someone's arm so I
can't take things away from him or
interact with him anymore I don't like
him
fappy her P la P Lihue losing
cool that should turn off the water and
that's it
damn you it seems too easy dude Lucas
just wants to be entertained
okay so I've turned off the water now I
need to light my candle and light the
goddamn birthday candles okay I hate
that thing not not a fan okay happy
[ __ ] birthday we did it
[Applause]
are you something bad
oh no get up get up get up get up get up
and oil pouring in can I get out water
no wait turn it off where's the water
where is it
I died I'm sorry I'm sorry I panicked
is that what's supposed to happen yeah
doesn't even if you reach the valve when
you try to turn it breaks off and burn
alive anyway
fun escape room though change of pace
well that guy is not a very good person
and he's gonna do that to me isn't he
maybe
Oh bars and tone for another 10 seconds
jeez guys mad English British what do
you mean
mad no what's bad for outside of the UK
people say mad I'm seeing it right now
you're mad yeah you said it I'm a hottie
no mad my hottie let's Michael mad my
heart is what they call him the Triple M
Mads Mikkelsen man has the same initials
mr. mad I would date this [ __ ] out of
him but like not in a sexual way it well
I but like it would mainly be I would
rock his world I don't know what you go
to the boyfriend I'm not even listening
to you alright so there's a molded
coming out you're sure of that but I'm
going this way
you better lock pick to you're loaded
okay I'm gonna go this way I just feel
safer okay
all right I need to save don't we agree
mm-hmm I think we're all in agreement
sure is safe save room right through the
Skorpion door over there are you talking
about in the house yeah I mean either
one I think it I think it's equidistant
no go in through no I'm due for saving
phone's not gonna kill you hey buddy
remember those two key cards will get
you into the party don't be late now let
me talk to me no no no first the party
is have you you could get in from the
courtyard so come on man everybody's
waiting for you okay
so we're well I'll go say it first all
right yeah god damn it
thank you for those enhanced rounds yes
before we forget let's do the shotgun
thing before we into the episode no ok
fine ok let's make a mental note to do
that before beginning of next episode
there's guys out there so put away the
hatchet I don't know what a [ __ ] they
don't let you got that I don't need that
tab anymore
sneaky you don't need I'm done
psychostimulants I don't think you need
what about the supplements well there
you go that should be good beginning a
next episode we'll get the get a shotgun
and then go kill some dudes mm-hmm how
did you feel what do you mean just as
good well some puzzles been afraid but
how are you been liking the game it's so
good it's definitely like one of my
favorites of this year already and I
haven't gotten like you know I don't
know where I'm at and I don't want to
know like I don't need to know if I'm
like halfway in or whatever but like I
feel like it's just so spectacularly
done I just go to Luke's birthday Poorna
up birthday party next I'm like really
excited yeah so you you got the snake II
know what you went down and got the
snake II I'm up this episode yeah you
got the snake key out of the cops body
you used it upstairs to go into the
master bedroom found a secret passageway
to the red card back to the basement yes
if you really wanted to you could can
you use that shortcut from the master
bedroom I don't know you went into
Lucas's room discovered that he locked
his friend of the attic for days until
he started to rot right I learned that
he is like really into mechanics and
making things and also into sports and
he's insane you did an escape room happy
birthday he didn't escape room and soon
because christmas is coming up we're
going to please
last episode or like of the year yeah I
leave on the 21st
when's that Monday or to Thursday first
let's just play like Monday or Tuesday
mm-hmm you probably do with a couple
episodes let's do a couple as of this
publishing polygon made this game their
number five of the year
oh wow I would expect it's gonna appear
on many lists IGN polygon it was my
number two personal game of the year
it's I've also made a top ten and it
made mine and you know it's that good I
really like this game in the second half
it's gonna be unfortunate but it is on
my list and that's why I put it on
really liked it too
yeah I feel very strongly that it's a I
don't know if Jemima liked it but I know
Dan Reicher did well sure he likes it
but he [ __ ] works for Capcom that
doesn't count
no all right well we will see you guys
on the next episode of Knievel don't
forget to Like and subscribe cuz it
helps GameSpot's they can make more of
this stuff and my friend Mike my Hardy
he needs this no I don't this is how
they give him treats at work when he
gets subscribed act like you're helping
me out I don't need a life this is for
him I do not need you to like or
subscribe don't let him leave a comment
below